want to go to senator mike braun in the
middle of all of this the indiana
republican joins us on the phone senator
thank you
for taking the time well the president's
made it clear as you know and your
democratic colleagues have made it clear
um that despite the strength in that
employment report
uh and that we don't need this that they
want this and they will likely
get this what do you say well they're
definitely going to get it
i'm literally here in the last three or
four votes
we've been up all night the only
accomplishment
uh for the uh american public would be
what you
heard the uh unemployment benefit will
uh
be at 300 bucks and we'll go i think
august or september but
neil if you uh would look into the
amendments that we've offered to flush
out some of the
stuff that is astounding in this bill
because ninety percent of it unrelated
to covet
gives you a simmer there was one
item a small amount in today's
denomination 390 million was from the
administrative fee
associated with the underlying
authorization
of 70 million for the sba
there was a group of uh ag loans that
were not only forgiven by ethnicity
but given a 20 dividend to boost
uh that's kind of when
i think people look into what's in it
that is
that wishlist that we've heard about
that's been rushed over here we've tried
to flush it out with roughly
25 to 30 amendments but there's more
than you can imagine
totally unrelated to covered relief
and the health care issue uh economies
rebounding back in the states that
had good business climates and
didn't have these massive shutdowns in
relation to the uh
disease itself and i think we do see it
started to tick up uh i think
uh stay over the next year or two and uh
what do we have five unpredicted gdp
growth for the first quarter
i don't need to explain what all that
might uh mean
when it comes to inflation raising its
head and we're simply not
needed we're borrowing every penny of it
to boot
well that's nothing new to your point
senator i i do wonder though a number of
the democrats with whom i've been
talking about this very subject senator
have been saying
well republicans are fine once to talk
about the deficits getting worse debt
building
uh you know it was a republican
president donald trump who
urged during the fall to go big and a
bigger
uh you know a stimulus plan would be
better than anything smaller in fact
his wishes were something more in total
than
than this at the time how do you answer
that that
it was fine for donald trump even going
bigger
back then not now well i think
first of all when he was doing it not to
make any excuse for how much or whether
it was too much
we were not at the stand land for those
activations were out
there tangible evidence that
we got the disease on the run
and we did roughly 4 trillion bipartisan
it was nearly i think the five bills
prior had 90 votes
plus on each of the five especially the
big ones
and you know i think you can make the
case that in general though this place
runs with
trillion dollar structural deficits
related mostly to
social security and there are only four
or five of us you know
that vote in ways that would show that
that
is an issue that's a problem that
preceded trump
don't know whether his forte was being a
fiscal conservative i think that
had to be shown yet but there's no doubt
about this
and most of the largesse comes from the
house
the senate on the democratic side didn't
add as much to it as i imagined
most of it came over from the house
which they're not going to change
and i think what the american public
needs to do is look into the details of
what's in the bill
in those eventing committees got rushed
over here thank goodness ron johnson
at least gave us uh close to a landmark
for our spouse to look at it then for it
to be read out loud
and then the webinar delay was due to
manchester uh wrestling uh with his side
on the plan to get the unemployment
benefit at 300 bucks
okay we'll watch it very closely senator
i know you're in the middle of all of
that and his vote-a-rama will go on
maybe for hours more but a vote it looks
like it to your point might
might be had tonight we'll see mike
braun the indiana republican
senator